solook was way ahead of his time
Patricia and rosanna arquette opened up
about Luke Perry's legacy and his
relationship with their late sibling
Alexis they were so close
I mean Luke was always there for Alexis
all the time
loved Alexis to death early on when Luke
started having success with Beverly
Hills 90210 there were stories that Luke
Perry's gay he's having a relationship
with Alexis circa and Luke never said it
wasn't true and when he was asked about
it later he said Wilton to deny that
would to be saying there would be
something wrong with it and there's
nothing wrong with that solook was way
ahead of his time
beautiful beautiful incredible person
grew up I mean he lived in our house I
didn't get to live with him because I'm
older than everybody but my mother my
mother loved him so much and one of the
memories I had was him bringing his
daughter Sophie as a baby when mom was
dying to the bed and she have this
beautiful newborn baby and he was quite
a beautiful human being and he was like
a real quintessential kind of cowboy
all-american exulted kind of male in 30
years I never heard him say one bad word
about anyone ET sat down with the
actresses as they were being honored
with the sisterhood visionaries award at
visionary women organizations second
annual International Women's Day
celebration well feels incredible I mean
I don't think that you start doing
political or activist work to be a
visionary or see yourself as a visionary
but to work with this group of people
visionary women they raise money and
they give it to all these incredible
charities that help with women and girls
and my sister I'm so honored to be here
with her because the work that she's
done she really was very brave to come
forward and to start this conversation
about sexual assault that other people
have been talking about for a very long
time but it hadn't really broken through
now all of these millions of people come
forward with their stories and are
finding healing and community and it's
rippled throughout the world
[Music]